[Musique]
avec la presse quotidienne régionale et
les télévisions
locale vous présente le club des
[Musique]
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
des territoires iftréard bonjour
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro et puis Catherine tricot bonjour
bonjour directrice de la revue regard on
va revenir avec vous sur la campagne des
européennes qui s'invite dans la colère
du monde agricole actuellement des
agriculteurs qui sont et bien vent
debout contre les normes
environnementales avec un duel à
distance he dans cette campagne entre
Jordane Bardella qui était allé voir les
agriculteurs ce weekend et puis Gabriel
Attal qui reçoit la fnsoa aujourd'hui et
puis on va parler ce matin de la
mobilisation des opposants à la loi
immigration qui continue quanttin et oui
Alexandre effectivement 160 cortèges ét
organisés partout en France hier on va
revenir sur ce qui s sur cette
mobilisation mais d'abord nous allons
parler des tarifs de l'électricité qui
ne cesse d'augmenter depuis 2 ans hier
soir Bruno Lemire a confirmé une hausse
entre 8,6 % et 9,8 % à partir du mois de
février une situation qui frappe de
plein fouet le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages au point que certains doivent
renoncer à se chauffer faute de pouvoir
payer leur factur reportage à Paris avec
Fabien
Réard quand elle est chez elle zizina
Sunda ne se par jamais de son châle elle
ne chauffe son salon que par
intermittence pas plus que sa chambre à
coucher j'ai dors avec ça c'est
couvertur là j'ai une couette encore
j'ajoute encore je chauffe avant de
dormir mais après j'tais l'échauffage
cette mère de quatre enfants habite un
appartement de quatre pièces situé sous
les toits équipé de double vitrage mais
quand même mal isolé dans les chambres
des enfants c'est pareil je chauffe
avant de dormir je fais jusqu'à 2 3h
j'tes et je les laisse dormir comme ça
avec des grosses souettes et le matin
ils ont Frid oui le matin ils ont Frid
oui Deb c'est ça il y a le chauffage là
mais jamais j'ai je
chauffe jamais même en faisant des
économies son salaire d'agent de cantine
scolaire ne permet pas à Madame Sunda de
payer ses factures octobre j'ai payé 243
€ Novembre Décembre 615 €. comme j'ai
pas assez de salairire pour payer des
fois je reste avec beaucoup de dettes
j'ai été coupé deux fois les courants m'
coupé même deux fois ça fait deux fois
c'est très chocant pour moi vu que j'ai
des enfants et tout il faut qu'il mange
il faut voilà la hausse des prix de
l'électricité constaté depuis bientôt 2
ans devrait se poursuivre en raison du
retour d'une taxe gelée jusqu'à présent
dans le cadre du bouclier tarifaire face
à cette hausse un seul levier pour les
particuliers faire des travaux
d'isolation cette association qui VI
vient en aide au locataire mal chauffé
accompagne aussi les bailleurs dans le
financement de leurs travaux dans le cas
de Madame saoda on est chez des
bailleurs sociaux voilà généralement les
bailleurs sociaux ils sont souvent
enclin à réaliser des travaux après c
démarches sont souvent très longues un
projet de travaux minimum c'est 3 ans
autant d'années d'unconfort
supplémentaire pour les locataires de
logement mal isolé au revenus souvent
modeste et bientôt confronté à des
factures encore plus
salé Catherine tricot je vous voyez
réagir pendant ce sujet de Fabien RER
quand on voit l'annonce faite par Bruno
Lemer le ministre de l'Économie
d'augmenter jusqu'à 9,8 % l'électricité
à partir du 1er février quand on voit la
situation de cette dame on peut dire
qu'il va y avoir une situation
d'inégalité d'injustice qui va se se
poursuivre oui moi ce que je me suis dit
c'est que d'une part on nous annonce
qu'on va baisser de 2 milliards les
impôts pour les classes moyennes mais
cette augmentation en terme de rapport
dans les caisses de l'État c'est 60
milliards donc on voit c'estàd que les
taxes faites sur l'électricité rapporte
euh et en fait c'est à ça aussi qu'ils
avaient en partie renoncé hein en
baissant parfois jusqu'à 0 % les taxes
pour faire face à l'augmentation mais on
voit que véritablement euh il y a un
enjeu économique très important pour
l'État mais aussi un enjeu économique
très important pour les familles puisque
au fond ces 60 milliards ils vont être
payés par nous par les familles les
consommateurs puisque c'est distinct les
taxes des familles et celles des
entreprises qui elles ne vont augmenter
que de 5 et5i %. ce qui est déjà
beaucoup pour les TPE par exemple c'est
quand même non négligeable ça veut dire
que c'est quand même des sommes très
considérables qu'on nous qu'on occulte
un tout petit peu derrière ça sera 13 €
ou 15 € par mois oui mais enfin au bout
du compte ça fait que cette dame elle
arrive pas à se chauffer ça c'était le
premier point et le 2ième point c'est
qu'il faut vraiment accélérer sur la sur
la réhabilitation thermique on se
souvient qu'il y a 2 ans le gouvernement
avait refusé un amendement qui avait été
voté majoritairement et compris par son
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale pour
donner 10 milliards pour la
réhabilitation 10 milliards que à mettre
en rapport avec les 60 milliardsin donc
10 milliards pour accélérer la
réhabilitation des bâtiments ça n'a pas
ça a été refusé par le gouvernement et
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
il y a c'était il y a 2 ans donc on
aurait pu avoir des dizaines des
centaines de milliers de logements
aujourd'hui réhabilité ou en cours de
réhabilitation pour être protégé du du
froid et du chaud d'ailleurs donc voilà
je pense qu'il y a quelque chose d'un
peu ératique dans la politique globale
mais on va en reparler peut-être un tout
petit peu plus tard TR cette hausse du
prix électricité qui est décidé au nom
et bien du redressement des finances
publiques de la fin du quoi qu'il en
coûte on voit qu'au final ça a frappé
encore plus les classes
populaires bah oui comme toujours mais
le problème c'est aussi la transition
énergétique c'est que l'énergie coûte
très cher et que l'énergie elle coûte
très cher parce qu'on est pas on est
obligé de sortir de plus en plus de
l'énergie fossile ce qu'on arrive pas à
faire il faut le dire et que on a fait
des mauvais choix et qu'on a pas su
faire suffisamment de prévention dans
notre pays c'est pas normal que dans
notre pays ou qui était le champion du
nucléaire on paye ces prix-là de
l'électricité alors que et bah pour des
raisons idéologiques pour des raisons de
mauvaises raisons on na pas on n pas
produit comme il fallait et donc on va
acheter rendez-vous compte qu'on va même
jusqu'à acheter de l'électricité à
l'étranger alors que normalement on
devrait être tout à fait autosuffisant
donc c'est pas normal alors
effectivement après il y a une deuxième
conséquence enfin un deuxème effet à
tout cela c'est que l'État était le
garant d'une certaine stabilité des prix
et puis il a décidé de sortir d'uneun
politique qui s'appelle la politique du
quoi qu'il en coûte c'estàd que l'État
se suppli se substituait aux
particuliers aux entreprises pour
assurer la différence et que maintenant
bah il est pris à la gorge il il peut
plus donc c'est vrai que c'est tout à
fait dommageable mais je dois dire que
on est largement responsable Catherine
tricot il y a quand même cette situation
de nos finances publiques et puis le
prix de l'électricité sur le marché qui
redevient plutôt normal et ce qui un
moment quand même il fallait sortir de
ce quoi qu'il en coûte et de ce bouclier
tarifaire sur l'électricité oui mais moi
je mais bien sûr je pense pas que ça
pouvait continuer éternellement c'est
évident alors par contre on peut
discuter de la le montant de la taxe
hein puisque ça représente 60 milliards
c'estàd qu'on pourrait discuter est-ce
que il faut aller il fallait remonter la
taxe jusqu'à ce point on savait que par
exemple du temps de Lionel josp il y
avait eu une taxe flottante sur le
montant de l'énergie euh ça ça pourrait
être un élément de discussion la
deuxième chose c'est que ce qu'on vient
de dire c'est qu'en fait l'énergie qui
coûte le moins cher c'est celle qu'on ne
dépense pas donc il faut accélérer
l'isolation des bâtiments c'est un
vraiment c'est fondamental c'est
fondamental pour le climat et c'est
fondamental pour le porte-monnaie des
gens et enfin troisème élément c'est que
vous avez raison Yve de dire qu'on a on
se trouve à avoir à racheter mais
aujourd'hui la situation de 2023 par
rapport à 2022 la différence cet hiver
c'est que l'année dernière il y avait
beaucoup de centrales nucléaires qui
étaient à l'arrêt ce n'est plus le cas
cette année et c'est relativement à la
marche et ponctuelle qu'on achète sur
les marchés qui est des centrales il y a
quelques centrales à gaz qui ont été
remises en activité on se souvient que
un jour il y a eu une centrale à charbon
mais globalement notre électricité elle
est produit par le par le nucléaire ce
qui n'est pas toute la question
énergétique puisqu'en France le
nucléaire ne représente qu'une part elle
part une part essentielle de notre
énergie mais en même temps pour tous les
transports et ben c'est ça reste encore
du pétrole et c'est ça qu'il va falloir
nucléaire qui coûte cher parce qu'on n
pas su de l'entretien bien sûr non mais
je suis d'accord le nucléaire il y a une
illusion que le nucléaire ne coûte pas
le nucléaire coûte cher mais mais
l'avant oui parce que c'est aussi une
énergie chère parce c'est une énergie
technique parce que c'est des matières
premières qui sont chères mais ceciétant
on on est en train de de se remettre à
niveau sur le nucléaire et reste toute
la partie la partie pétrole je dirais
alors le problème si vous voulez c'est
que ça ça fait partie de la transition
énergétique mais effectivement le le le
j'allais dire la remise
à jour des des
habitations pour que ça éviter que ça
soit des passoirs thermiques ça coûte
une fortune ça coûte une fortune et qui
va payer encore qui va payer ben c'est
l'état y a des a de l'État avec la
fameuse ma prime Ren exactement je suis
pas en train de critiquer mais ça va'
coûter une fortune une fortune et donc
ça pose une question majeure mais ça va
ça va c'est ça va parce que pour
l'instant ça ça ne coûte pas une fortune
non mais dire c'est que ma prime r pr
non mais mais parce que ma prime rénov
ça n' pas marché ils ont fait une telle
usine à gaz tellement compliqué que ça
n'a pas fonctionné et politiquement on
est quand même à quelques mois d'un
scrutin les élections européennes ça
paraît extrêmement risqué pour le
gouvernement d'annoncer comme ça une
hausse de taxes sur l'électricité de 10
%. bien sûr que ça peut oui enfin ils
font en sorte que ça n'atteigne pas tout
à fait 10 % mais effectivement vous
avez oui non mais vous avez raison mais
évidemment mais c'est c'est le problème
majeur d'ailleurs des élections qui vont
avoir lieu dans tous les pays
d'Europe qui et on va le voir avec le
sujet agricole parce que tous ces
sujetsl sont des sujets de
mécontentement qui sont des sujets de
mécontentement qui vont avoir des des
répercussions sur le sur le vote
évidemment éid et vous pensez que les
Français peuvent comprendre finalement
ce discours de responsabilité de
redressement des finances publiques
voilà on a bien protégé avec le bouclier
maintenant il s'agit de de redresser les
comptes si euh ça va ça va être
compliqué mais je il va falloir qu'il le
comprenne 97 milliards de dividendes ont
été versé cette
année par ben c'est non ça si ça à voir
ça voirel ce sera une question de
justice fiscale exactement c'estd que ce
que je veux dire je ne dis pas qu'on
peut continuellement fonctionner de
cette manière moi encore une fois je
pense qu'il faut agir sur le structurel
donc en particulier il faut rénover les
bâtiments et il faut qu'on change notre
consommation énergétique mais ceci étant
il y a quand même une question de
justice fiscale c'est que là on augmente
et on va ramener 60 milliards dans les
caisses pris sur les Français tout un
chacun vous moi et cetera alors que il y
a 97 milliards de dividendes qui ont été
versés par les entreprises
françaises mais oui c'est un éternel
débat c'est même quand vous faites
l'impôt sur la fortune les choses vont
pas mieux vous vous apercevez de ça et
on ne pourra pas résoudre ce débat ici
on va ouvrir le deuxième thème de ce
club des territoires on va parler de la
loi immigration puisque Quentin et hier
il y avait 160 rassemblements qui été
organisés en France à 4 jours de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
cette loi immigration voilà les
opposants à cette loi étaient réuni
étaient réunis partout en France
effectivement ils étaient 75000 d'après
le ministère de l'Intérieur 150000
d'après la CGT principal cortège celui
qui s'était lancé de la place du
Trocadero à Paris 16000 personnes selon
la police dans la capitale à l'origine
de cet appel à manifesté 201
personnalités du monde du spectacle et
de la politique qui ont signé une
tribune dans le journal l'Humanité
marchons pour la liberté l'égalité et la
fraternité avec également par parmi les
organisateurs les syndicats tels que la
CGT ou la CFDT écoutez Sophie Binet la
secrétaire générale de la CGT
aujourd'hui nous sommes là pour exhorter
le président de la République à prendre
ses responsabilités à ne pas promulguer
cette loi qui déshonore la France qui
divise le pays et qui la l'entâche d'une
tâche indélébile vis-à-vis de l'É de
l'international notamment nous sommes là
pour appeler le Premier ministre à
renoncer à la réforme de l'aide médicale
d'État qui l'a réaffirmé récemment alors
que il sad dit d'une réforme scandaleuse
d'un point de vue humain et dangereuse
d'un point de vue de d'un point de vue
sanitaire on va faire le tour d'horizon
des des réactions politiques hier
puisqu'on a vu beaucoup de personnalités
notamment de gauche dans la
manifestation il y avait les communistes
les écologistes les socialistes les
insoumis comme quoi les tensions de la
Nupe pouvaient se faire oublier parfois
hier écoutez Fabien Roussel le
secrétaire national du PCF quelques
heures avant le début de la
manifestation cette loi a été voté
négocié avec la droite et l'extrême
droite vootter avec leur voix et et
maintenant euh bien sûr que nous allons
nous mobiliser pour défendre euh la
dignité humaine voilà pour défendre la
dignité humaine du côté de la majorité
présidentielle on se défend de toute
reprise des idées du RN écoutez la
ministre Aurore berger il y a pas de
préférence nationale dans le texte selon
elle je ne peut pas laisser dire que ce
ce que la préférence nationale a été
mise en place ça n'est pas vrai clar
gtinois ça n'est pas texte mais ça n'est
pas la mise en place de la préférence
nationale dis distinguer des
travailleurs
étrangers aujourd'hui dans la capacité
que vous avez par exemple à percevoir le
RSA vous avez déjà des conditions qui
sont différentes en fonction de votre
durée d'ancienneté sur le territoire
national allez dernière réaction on va
écouter Éric Zemour le chef de fil de
reconquête qui se dit opposé à la loi
immigration mais pour des raisons
opposées à celles des manifestants
écoutz hier cette loi il n'y aura rien
il n'y a rien dedans il y a pire que
rien comme je l'ai dit parce que il y a
la régularisation de 10000 clandestins
en plus des 30000 qu'on régularise tous
les ans c'est ça que le RN et LR ont
voté je tiens à le dire moi ce que je
vois c'est les résultats à long terme à
long terme il y aura toujours le droit
du sol il y aura toujours le droit au
regroupement familial il y aura toujours
les 150000 droits d'asile on ne fait
rien contre excusez-moi ça ne changera
rien fin du suspense autour de ce texte
immigration je dit avec la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel qui doit dire
s'il censure une partie du texte
Catherine tricot vous étiez à la
manifestation hier et qu'est-ce que vous
en retenit il y avait du monde et il y
avait ce que j'ai retenu c'est qu'il y
avait du monde j'ai l'habitude des
manifestations il y avait pas de Band
rollle et quand il y a pas de banderôle
ça veut dire que c'est les citoyens qui
sont venus ce n'est pas venu par les
organisations c'était vraiment
d'ailleurs c'est pas une manifestation
il y avait pas beaucoup de slogans il y
avait des gens qui sont venus dire
qu'ils ne veulent pas de ça qu'ils ont
honte il ils n'en veulent pas pour les
gens qui vont être affectés on sait que
cette loi a été votée sans avoir fait
une étude d'impact préalable c'est qu'on
ne savait pas quelle seraient les les
impacts de cette loi et commence à
sortir la presse commence à le faire on
sait par exemple que de deux femmes qui
travaillent à mi-temps comme assistante
sociale l'une va toucher 650 € l'autre
actuellement elle avait des aides parce
qu'elle était élevée un enfant seul elle
avait un logement et ça lui permettait
de vivre de survivre et de vivre
correctement enfin autour 2500 € l'une
va tout perdre restera avec 650 c'està
direire qu'elle va être en dans un état
d'extrême pauvreté elle ne pourra plus
payer son loyer elle ne pourra plus
élever son enfant tandis que l'autre va
conserver deux femmes qui ont exactement
la même situation donc c'est à la fois
une une loi qui va rendre très difficile
on évalue à 110000 personnes qui vont
être dans une situation très grave avec
cette loi et ça les touche eux et ça
nous affecte nous moi je je suis blessé
que dans mon pays on fasse ça c'est que
c'est mon humanité et c'est ça que j'ai
entendu dans la manifestation hier
est-ce que vous pensez que ces
manifestations antiou émigration ça peut
faire bouger Emmanuel Macron ou est-ce
qu'il est déjà passé à autre chose et
que la loi va être
promulguées c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel qui peut éventuellement
corriger certaines choses moi je pense
que c'est une loi qui sert à rien du
tout quoi qu'il arrive c'est une loi qui
est sans effet c'est une le sujet c'est
quoi c'est pas l'humanité le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir comment on
maîtrise l'immigration cles av question
de l'intégration quand même dans la loi
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a qui concerne
l'intégration la préférence nationale
vous allez n'importe où en Europe ce
sujet existe vous avez préférenceces
nationales partout mais partout on peut
pas dire que ça si vous vous permettez
donc c'est pas c'est pas un sujet à mon
avis cette loi elle a beaucoup de
défauts elle a un seul défaut c'est
qu'elle ne résout rien c'est qu'elle ne
prévoit rien sur l'intégration
absolument rien contrairement à ce qu'on
dit régularisé oui oui vous régularisez
so wat ça améliore pas le sort des gens
et deuxièmement le deuxème sujet
c'était et le premier
d'ailleurs si on regarde dans le dans le
temps c'était la loi était surtout faite
pour ça
comment maîtriser davantage les flux
migratoires clandestins ça ne résout
absolument rien ça va pas réduire les
délis les dossers mais ça mais les
dossiers il y a moindre cours je sais
pas on on va voir on va voir mais une
fois que vous avez décidé que ce qui est
d'ailleurs le cas pour la plupart
d'entre eux il faut le dire la plupart
des demandeurs d'asile sont déboutés il
faut le dire mais la plupart aussi quand
ils sont déboutés restent en France
comment vous les renvoyez dans leur pays
je ne connais pas un seul parti
politique y compris le monsieur qui
était derrière vous tout à l'heure qui
s'appelle éc Zemour qui a la solution
appliquer les octf qui sont
qui qui a la solution personne on ment
on ment aux gens tout le monde ment aux
gens y compris l'extrême droite telle
qu'elle est présentée je suis par que
personne ne sait comment les renvoyer
vous vous vous savez que on va on va le
dire très prosaïquement
un un immigré clandestin qui est frappé
d'une
TF quand il s'agit de le renvoyer sur
chez lui vous le présentez ou il se
présente dans un premier temps avant que
ça soit plus musclé et c'est à lui de
partir il part pas il est contrôlé et on
le renvoie vous le présentez à une
compagnie aérienne le seul qui est maîre
à bord ben c'est le commandant de bord
précisément et pour la paix du voyage et
bien il refuse de prendre le l'immigré
en question dans son avion qui par
ailleurs ne peut pas débarquer c'estd
que par ailleurs les sur place voilà
donc moi je suis je souscris tout tout à
fait avec ce que vient de dire if trar
ça ne répond en rien ni à l'objectif
d'intégration ni à celui de régler la
question des flux migratoires en en rien
tout ça par contre là où je il y a une
divergence avec vous c'est que je pense
ça rend plus difficile la vie des gens
qui sont ici et qui font vivre nos
hôpitaux qui s'occupent de nos enfants
de nos vieux qui construisent nos
bâtiments et nos routes c'est que ça
rend difficile ceux qui sont là mais ça
ne règ en rien les autres problèmes
Catherine tricoot il y a une échéance
cette semaine c'est l'avis du Conseil
constitutionnel sur cette loi
immigration et ce qui est étonnant c'est
que même le gouvernement même l'exécutif
attend cet avis du conseil avec
éventuellement des mesures qui vont être
retoquées des mesures rajoutées par les
républicains et l'exécutif et bien voilà
et un peu dans dans l'expectative en
espérant que certaines mesures vont être
enlev du texte c'est une tarabistouille
incroyable enfin franchement moi
politiquement je ne comprends pas
comment un président de la République et
un gouvernement emène une loi devant le
Conseil constitutionnel il y avait
quelle était l'urgence hein d'aller
deire voter cette loi avant de avoir
vérifié sa légalité ce qui est le
processus normal là ils ne l'ont pas
fait pour des raisons politiques le
Président il avait décidé que à Noël on
aurait terminer l'affaire et qu'il
fallait que ce soit voté avant et cetera
et c'est je trouve que c'est un
affaiblissement des procédures
démocratiques et de et un
affaiblissement de de la façon de
fabriquer la loi je pense que
véritablement on n pas besoin de ça en
ce moment d'affaisser encore un peu plus
tout ce qui fait le fonctionnement
démocratique de notre pays Yv ça nous
rappelle que finalement cette loi
immigration qui est sortie au final
c'est pas vraiment le texte de la
majorité présidentielle ah B non c'est
le c'est évidemment pas le texte de la
majorité présidentielle c'est le texte
de la majorité du Sénat euh en
partie effectivement c'est une une
grande victoire à l'époque c'était une
grande victoire pour les républicains
après c'est assez curieux effectivement
je suis assez d'accord d'un qu'un
gouvernement se dise tiens c'est le
Conseil constitutionnel c'est le
gouvernement des juges alors c'est le
Conseil constitutionnel qui décide si
c'est légal ou pas donc si c'est
constitutionnel ou pas il a raison de
présidenttion a continuer à à légiférer
de la sorte et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement le chef du gouvernement
Gabriel Atal qui a promis de mettre en
œuvre une réforme de l'aide médicale
d'État qui permet de soigner les
étrangers en situation irrégulière une
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État qui
est souhaitée par les républiquains donc
ça veut dire que la la bataille sur ce
sujet de l'immigration elle est pas
finie cette année c'est tout à fait
certain c'est un accord qui avait été
passé entre les républicains et Madame
bande quand elle était premier ministre
et ça a été la condition pour le vote
donc on a bien conscience que l'aide
médicale d'État si elle réformé c'est
pas pour en élargir son périmètre mais
au contraire pour le restreint donc ce
qu'on revient voilà on revient à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est qu'en
fait la fin le au résultat cette loi n'a
qu'un effet c'est de rendre plus
difficile la vie des gens qui vivent sur
notre territoire et qui encore une fois
c'est 40 % des emplois qui s'occupent
des enfants et des vieillards c'est 40 %
des emplois dans le bâtiment on va faire
les Jeux Olympiques sans eux il y aurait
pas de jeux olympiques à Paris c'est ve
dire que ces gens qui sont là qu'on met
dans une précarité immense c'est eux qui
s'occupent de nos enfants c'est eux qui
s'occupent de nos vieux c'est eux qui
font les Jeux Olympiques c'est 3000
médecin à la PHP qui risque de d'être
d'être renvoyé chez eux alors qu'on n
pas de médecin non mais je veux dire on
marche sur la tête cette loi est absurde
et elle va désorganiser un peu plus
notre pays si elle était appliquée mais
elle ne le sera pas et mais en tout cas
vous êtes non les B de la PHP ils sont
pas clandestins hein non ils sont pas
clandestins mais le c'est la fin pas cl
ILT pas
régularise pas on prolonge pas leurat le
le droit de vivre dans le territoire
donc du coup leur contrat à la PHP est
en cause ils ont manifesté à ce propos
3000 d'entre eux ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est c'est beaucoup c'est
vous allez dans pédiatrie ou aux
urgences vous allez vous rendre compte
que ce sont souvent des médecins
étrangers qui s'occupent des bébés et
qui s'occupent des urgences et on
continuera à parler de cette loi
immigration tout au long de cette
semaine on va finir ce club par en
évoquant et bien la campagne des
élections europées qui s'invite dans la
colère actuelle du monde agricole une
colère des agriculteurs contre les
normes environnementales et ça le tête
de list du rassemblement national aux
européennes Jordan Bardella patron du
parti et bien ça ne lui a pas échappé et
donc il est venu ce weekend au chevet
des agriculteurs on l'écoute le monde
agricole lui est important pour la
France et on entend pas le laisser
mourir dans l'indifférence généralisée
je pense qu'il y a un mouvement de
colère qui est en train de se lever
aujourd'hui partout en Europe et le
point commun de ce mouvement de colère
c'est l'Union européenne et l'Europe de
Macron euh qui veut la mort de notre
agriculture qui ne cesse de la mettre en
concurrence avec des produits agricoles
qui viennent du bout du monde Yve ça y
est la campagne est lancée finalement
c'est c'est une opportunité pour Jordan
Bardella de cette crise agricole
finalement d'arriver de dire que c'est
la faute de l'Europe et c'est la faute
d'Emmanuel Macron oui enfin le sujet
c'est pas Jordan Bader c'est les les
agriculteurs bien sûr sur le fond mais
est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il y a une
récupération politique c'est ça bah
évidemment euh c'est évident mais
surtout que le rassemblement national
bon maintenant est assez installé dans
le monde
rural et et dans le monde périurbain on
va dire mais le le vrai problème c'est
le sujet le problème agricole alors
évidemment qu'il va récupérer récolter
des voies grâce à cette à cette campagne
qu'il essaie de de conduire dans les
campagnes c'est le cas de le dire avec
un monde agricole qui est qui a raison
d'être très très inquiet parce que bah à
cause de des normes européennes qui
poussent à la transition énergétique
c'est vrai mais euh Jordan Bardella a
raison quand il dit le problème agricole
c'est la faute de l'Europe non c'est pas
la faute de l'Europe uniquement c'est le
fait que on doit changer notre modèle de
production agricole tout le monde on est
conscient mais comment on le change à
quelle rapidité à quelle à quel rythme
et et comment et et malheureusement les
agriculteurs sont démunis face à cela
ils font face à une bureaucratie qui est
absolument euh euh considérable et qui
qui évidemment les handicapent
considérablement aujourd'hui un poulet
sur deux est importé alors que il y a
encore 20 ans c'était un poulet sur 4
donc ça vous donne toute l'ampleur du
problème qui existe chez les
agriculteurs alors pas tous les
agriculteurs parce que les céréaliers
s'en sortent plutôt assez bien mais
c'est plutôt l'élevage qui fait les
frais de cette bureaucratie et de ce
changement actuel tout comme d'ailleurs
la production de fruits légumes
Catherine tricot est-ce que le
diagnostic de Jordan Bardella la faute
la responsabilité de l'Europe sur cette
crise agricole est le bon ou est-ce
qu'on est dans une forme de des
récupération démagogique euh je pense
qu'il dit il enfile des perles un petit
peu hein en disant que ça va mal moi je
veux dire absolument tout le monde est
d'accord il n'y a personne qui pense
qu'on peut continuer d'avoir des
agriculteurs qui vivent avec des revenus
qui sont proches de 700 € voire en
dessous voire négatif c'estàd que même
c'est même la profession on se suicide
le plus et on est dans un une une forme
de souffrance considérable dans la
souffrance il y a un problème par
exemple qui n'est jamais évoqué c'est
celui de l'exposition aux pesticides
c'est quand même aussi une profession
qui est extrêmement affectée par le
problème du cancer je pense qu'on ne
peut pas raconter que les choses sont
simplement comment dire qu'elles peuvent
continuer ainsi qu'il y a des méchants
qui veulent faire bouger les choses on
ne peut pas continuer par exemple je
voyais par la la Hollande c'est un pays
qui sont en train de pourrir les eau
avec l'azote qui sont en train
d'infiltrer je dire que c'est c'est
impensable de se dire que ça peut
continuer ainsi avec les fertilisant
avec les pesticides avec les produits
azotés c'est pas simplement un problème
énergétique c'est aussi un problème de
de de de considérer que notre sol nos
napes fréatiques sont notre matière
première et je suis d'accord avec vous
il faut les accompagner pour faire cette
transition donc je crois que le le
l'objectif affiché par par l'Europe est
juste la manière de le faire comme bien
souvent c'est bureaucratique c'est ça
manque un peu de subtilité et c'est
souvent assez inégalitaire comme vient
de le rappeler if trard c'est vraiment
les séréaliés les plus gros qui tirent
le le bénéfice maximum de la de la PAC
et par contre beaucoup moins les petites
les petites exploitations donc je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose à revoir mais
pas remettre en cause le fait qu'il faut
une transition véritablement en
profondeur de l'agriculture pour les
agriculteurs pour ce que nous mangeons
et pour la préservation de nos sols et
de nos eau Yve le Premier ministre
Gabriel Atal est aussi au chevet des
agriculteurs puisqu'il reçoit
aujourd'hui la FNSA le principal
syndicat agricole est-ce que dans cette
situation de crise le gouvernement n'a
d'autre choix que de reculer de faire
des concessions aux agriculteurs
notamment peut-être reculer sur une
hausse de taxes sur le gazol non routier
qui a été prévue par l'État oui oui oui
bien sûr dans la crise aussi il y a les
changements alimentaires il y a les
changements d'habitude des consommateurs
he faut pas oublier ça hein vous avez
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui une par exemple
en France les gens qui mangent de la
viande tous les jours ce qui était le
cas vraisemblablement il y a quelques
années c'est plus du tout le cas
aujourd'hui donc ça vous rendez compte
ça change complètement le la donne alors
effectivement la la le gouvernement va
s'employer il a tout intérêt parce que
ce que redoute le gouvernement c'est que
les gilets jaunes se transforment en
gilets jaunes en en gilets vert donc il
il a évidemment il va évidemment prendre
des mesures avec une séquence qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui et qui va jusquau
jusqu'au salon d'agriculture qui est
dans un mois voilà on parle énormément
d'agriculture tous les ans à porte de
versaill donc c'est un long ça peut être
un long
tunnel long une longue séquence
politique et de évidemment de
négociation ou de face à faceace avec
les agriculteurs les agriculteurs qui
sont vendbout contre cette hausse de
taxes sur le gazol n routier
effectivement Catherine tricot on a
l'impression qu'on va revivre un nouvel
épisode des gilets jaunes oui c'est ce
qu'on dit c'est qu'en fait si si
l'application elle est faite de façon
brutale et sans accompagnement pour
changer même le matériel
utilise les agriculteurs je vois pas
comment on peut s'en sortir mais je
voulais dire tout à l'heure que il y
avait un un effet chaotique de cette
politique c'est que on nous explique que
la priorité c'est des classes moyennes
on augmente de façon sensible et forte
l'électricité et puis là la priorité ça
va être les agriculteurs c'estàd qu'en
fait on ne sait pas et au fond je pense
qu'ils ne savent pas parce que
véritablement et c'est ce que révèle la
la crise politique mondiale avec la
montée des extrêmes droites dans le
monde entier c'est qu'au fond au bout de
30 40 ans de dérégulation généralisée on
a assommé les les les gens qui n'ont
finalement que leur travail pour pour
vivre qui ne sont pas des rentiers qui
n'ont pas des revenus du patrimoine et
que tous ces gens-là sont en train
souffre dans tous les pays et du coup se
tourne vers l'extrême droite et on va
vers une crise politique d'une ampleur
considérable avec les enjeux de tension
militaire que cela peut provoquer avec
le fait qu'on va risque de prendre de
faire une marche arrière sur les enjeux
de transition environnementale dans
leurs différentes dimensions donc là il
faut se poser la question du modèle
économique et sur lequel le gouvernement
est installé et Emmanuel Macron en étant
un de ses plus grands euh ENF
contempteurs c'està-dire le le
libéralisme la concurrence
l'efficacité économique étroite moi je
crois que c'est ça qui est en train de
nous mettre politiquement dans un mur je
ne sais pas comment l'Europe peut s'en
remettre d'une chose comme ça on va
continuer à évoquer cette crise du monde
agricole puisque c'est à la Une de
certains quotidiens régionaux tout de
suite la revue de
[Musique]
presse
et Quentin la mobilisation des
agriculteurs qui est aujourd'hui à la
une du Midi Libre exactement avec
toujours les mêmes revendications on en
parlait sur les normes les revenus
l'accès à l'eau les agriculteurs en ont
marre point d'exclamation titre ce matin
journal de Montpellier le ministre de
l'Agriculture Marc fenau est interrogé
dans le journal tout ce que l'on peut
simplifier on le fera il explique que
son projet de loi sera bien présenté au
premier semestre avec un nouveau volet
qu'il veut sur les simplifications les
sindicat agricole Alex qui sont reçus à
Matignon à 17h vous le disiez Arnaud
Rousseau le président de la fnsoa attend
un chapelet de mesure dit-il et il a
averti dans le journal n'imaginez pas
que la colère va retomber parce que je
rencontre le Premier ministre c'est le
terrain qui commande le terrain gronde
le mal est profond les agriculteurs sont
en colère mais les pêcheurs aussi
puisque le journal Sud-Ouest et bien
évoque l'interdiction de pêcher qui va
concerner une partie des pêcheurs de la
côte atlantique oui voyez ce titre
dauphin en danger pêcheurs à l'arrêt
dans le golfe de gazcogne ce sont près
de 450 bateaux français interdit de
pêche pour protéger les dauphins une
mesure inédite avec des indemnités à la
clé et une interdiction prise pour une
durée d'un mois il faut dire que le
nombre de dauphins échoués sur la côte a
bondi de quelques dizaines dans les
années 70 à plus de 1400 l'an dernier le
procès des attentats de treb s'ouvre
aujourd'hui voilà 7 prévenu proche du
terroriste radouine lacdim comparaissent
à Paris jusqu'au 23 février c'est lors
de cet attentat car Nobel tram a été tué
le lieutenant colonel avait pris la
place d'une otage les partis civiles
redoutent dans le journal que ces
audiences ne leur apportent au final que
peu de réponse écrit La Dépêche Alex on
s'arrête sur une interview du président
de l'exécutif Corse à la Une de Corse
Matin on n'oublie pas le dossier Corse
même si Orian manchini n'est pas là ce
matin mais effectivement Gill Simeon
réitère cette argument pour une
évolution institutionnelle de la Corse
dans le contexte de reprise d'attentat
et de tension sociale sur l'île Gill
Siméoni qui parle d'un point de bascule
pour l'Î en 2024 mais selon lui un
chemin est possible sur le plan
institutionnel et politique et puis
commeorian on a l'habitude B on finit
cette revue de presse par du foot voilà
effectivement on a vécu les 16e de
finales de la Coupe de France ce weekend
Alexandre le rassing Club de Strasbourg
s'est imposé à Clermont Paris Normandie
qui parle de l'exploit du FC rouan en 12
tirs au but contre 11 pour Toulouse et
c'est aussi après une interminable
séance de tir au but que l'OM a été
sorti par Rennes votre club c'était pas
c'était pas pour me déplaire
voilà merci beaucoup Quentin merci
d'avoir participé à ce club des
territoires on va regarder Catherine la
Une de votre revue regard pour ce mois
de janvier consacré à la nomination de
Gabriel Atal par Emmanuel Macron avec ce
titre Sarkozi
président et puis il on va regarder la
Une du journal Le Figaro aujourd'hui qui
est consacré à cette crise du monde
agricole ce titre agriculteur la colère
monte en France et en Europe merci
beaucoup c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi si vous
voulez revoir cette émission vous pouvez
la retrouver sur notre plateforme
publicsena.fr et puis prochain
rendez-vous sur publicsena à 18h sens
public présenté par Thas HUG on se
retrouve on se retrouve demain à très
bonne journée sur Public
Sénat